okay welcome back everybody so I want to
ask a question because I'm a little bit
torn about the homework and exam
situation because I don't like exams and
I don't want to give you a ridiculously
long homework five so how many of you
would be like terribly disappointed if I
swapped out the final for a sixth
homework how many of you think that was
okay show of hands how many would prefer
to have a final okay I wish there were
more of you in here to vote all the
sides soon but I'm leaning strongly
towards having a sixth homework instead
of a final exam so I think what I would
probably do is write the final exam and
give it to you and you can do it like a
homework and if you want to take it in
two hours to prepare for Qualls that's
fine and then if you want to spend more
time on it that's also fine because I
really want to ask questions that will
be in next week's material on the exam
or on the sixth homework but I don't
want to bury you with homework this week
okay and then last question would you
rather have me split up the six
homeworks with 80% or would you rather
the sixth homework be worth 20% split
them up even
okay all right so all the sides soon on
Monday you'll know I might ask you again
so if anyone has a huge objection email
me yeah okay good so today I'm excited I
want to teach you a lot of cool stuff
about the Laplace transform so last time
we learned about the Laplace transform
and how it's useful for solving OD es
and this time I'm going to essentially
build on this to talk about how you
would solve OD use with external forcing
so this is the basis of looking at
system responses to vibrations feedback
control a ton of very very very useful
things okay so I'm just gonna give you
the teaser of an extremely large and
extremely important topic and there's I
think dozens of classes that go more
into depth on what I'm about to tell you
okay
dozens of classes at the U dub thousands
of classes nationwide okay so we're
gonna revisit the spring mass damper and
I brought a spring mass damper from my
office so no one try to call me this is
my spring mass damper so we're gonna do
some demos except now what we're gonna
do is we're gonna add an external
forcing to our spring mass damper system
okay so I'm just gonna rewrite what we
have and kind of summarize the steps
from the last lecture okay we have a
spring with spring constant K a damper
with damping rate C and a mass with mass
and okay and we can write this down as X
double dot plus some constants a right
now some constant a I guess I could
literally call that constant C
X dot plus K X double dots but now
instead of looking at this equal to zero
I'm going to look at this equal to some
external forcing did I mess up the signs
yeah Joe no sex no double dots there
okay and instead of being equal to zero
we're gonna have this equal to two U of
T which is our external forcing term
let's see if I can get some colors going
here and by external forcing I mean this
thing actually has units of acceleration
or mass normalized force right because
it's equal to X double dot so this thing
has the same units as acceleration or
force if you will and you can imagine
that maybe I have a piece of metal in
here and a big electromagnet and I can
add some force to this thing okay okay
and maybe I also have some initial
conditions so for a concrete example I'm
just gonna pick some numbers and we're
always going to be working with X double
dot plus five X dot plus four x equals U
of T because this thing factors nicely
when you do the Laplace transform and
I'm also going to give it some initial
conditions X at time zero and X dot at
time zero equals two and negative five
and I just want to kind of I'm just
summarizing what we did last time so I'm
gonna color code this also as orange so
my initial conditions are gonna be in
orange maybe not my initial conditions
are going to be red
okay and we're gonna Laplace transform
this look at the solution and then start
breaking it down into pieces
okay so when we Laplace transform this
equation what did we get last time
what's the Laplace transform of the left
hand side plus transform some stuff
Laplace transform special it gets curly
brackets s squared plus 5 s plus 4 times
X bar my Laplace function so it's really
easy to read off the Laplace transform
of this because every derivative is just
another power of s and I would also get
some initial condition terms and I could
bring them all over to the right-hand
side and say that that's equal to 2's
plus 5 and also now I have my Laplace
transform of forcing plus u bar of s so
I went from the time domain into the
frequency domain now is everyone okay
with me calling my Laplace transform the
frequency domain
I go from time to frequencies s s is
just a generalized Fourier coefficient
so it could be I Omega in which case
it's a pure tone frequency or it could
be lambda plus I Omega which is the
frequency and a decay rate okay and
these terms I'm gonna keep track of then
I have my forcing term and I also have
my initial my initial condition term
okay so what are the general like what's
the general procedure for solving this
system now that I have it in the Laplace
domain
okay good okay that's far isolated so
I've divided by my characteristic
polynomial and then inverse Laplace
transform maybe I knew some partial
fractions in the middle okay good so I'm
just gonna go through all of the math
one time like we've already done this so
X bar s is equal to my initial
conditions divided by my characteristic
call on a meal to s plus five divided by
s squared plus 5s plus or plus my
forcing term times one over my
characteristic polynomial okay and I can
break this up in partial fractions we
did that last time it's just 1 over s
plus 1 plus 1 over s plus 4 and the
coefficients here are essentially my
constant coefficients determined by my
initial conditions plus this function
here times us so this is just review at
this point and now if I want to inverse
Laplace transform this I say okay now
I'm gonna inverse Laplace transform and
I get X of T my time domain function
which is what I really want cuz we all
live in the time domain we don't live in
the frequency domain or do we I don't
know we might so we inverse Laplace
transform each of these terms separately
and they add because these are it's a
linear operator the Laplace transforms
linear on these terms so what's the
inverse Laplace transform of 1 over s
plus a e to the minus 80 and so here a
is 1 and 4 so we have e to the minus 1
times time plus e to the minus 4 times
time Plus this thing inverse Laplace
transform plus inverse Laplace transform
of this whole forcing term
now what is the Laplace what is the
inverse Laplace transform of the product
of two functions the convolution of the
inverse Laplace transforms of each of
the terms so I take the inverse Laplace
transform of the first term and I didn't
ever prove that to you
I never proved that the inverse Laplace
transform of a product is the
convolution but if you actually plug it
in it's super easy to show that it's the
convolution and you can google this big
believer of Google the guy who basically
programmed most of Google at least early
Google gave a talk here yesterday Jeff
Dean if any of you heard of Jeff Dean so
he was the creator of MapReduce he
basically programmed the scalability of
the Google algorithm so it could work on
like millions of pores and humongous
data it's probably one of the most
famous programmers in the world he's
been called the Jeff the the Chuck
Norris of programming not the Jeff Dean
of programming not sure where this came
from okay so but you can google this and
Jeff Dean will tell you that the inverse
Laplace transform of this product is the
convolution of each of the inverse
Laplace transforms of the two terms okay
and what's the inverse Laplace transform
of u bar U of T okay so this was super
easy okay so let's go back to the color
coding here we have our initial
condition terms our initial condition
terms and these are our initial
condition response if I had no forcing
then I would just have this initial
condition response then in purple I have
my plus forcing term so here's my plus
forcing term plus forcing term plus
forcing term so if I had zero initial
conditions I would just have the purple
terms okay and the last thing we need to
do is figure out how to inverse Laplace
transform this function right if we can
do this we have everything else make
sense
okay so how might I go about doing this
how would I go about inverse Laplace
transform that nasty one over a
quadratic function of second order
polynomial and s that we do partial
fractions right we just do partial
fractions and now it's like a different
initial condition response where this is
the term we're trying to to solve for
okay so let's just do a simplification
let's for now assume we have no initial
conditions so assume zero ICS and this
is just for simplicity then our function
X of T is equal to the inverse Laplace
transform of 1 over s squared plus 5 s
plus 4 convolution with you my function
you have T my forcing function ok so we
want to in we want to find this inverse
Laplace transform and we're going to do
this using partial fractions so let's
just do that really really quickly and
before I do this I want to just write
down something so essentially what this
is a statement of this is in time domain
this is the solution of my system with
forcing in the frequency domain X bar of
s is just equal to this function times u
bar of s and so what I can do is I can
take X bar of s divided by u bar of s
and I can see that that's equal to this
function
one over s squared plus 5 s plus 4 and
I'm gonna give this really special
function a name I'm going to call it the
transfer function so we're gonna call
this G of s we're gonna box it and we're
gonna give this a name we're gonna call
this the transfer function and I call it
the transfer function because it tells
me essentially if I if I have some input
you this function tells me how much
output X I get for this amount of input
you okay so this is the transfer
function from u to X and we're gonna
look a little lot more at this transfer
function and what its properties are so
I just want to tell you that this thing
has a name this thing we're about to
inverse Laplace transform is called the
transfer function okay and it's
essentially 1 over my system dynamics
it's 1 over my characteristic polynomial
in s it's given completely by the
coefficients of my OD e ok so to compute
this inverse Laplace transform we
essentially do partial fractions so we
say we have 1 over s squared plus 5 s
plus 4 and how do I do partial fractions
i factor it I just say this is 1 over
sorry a over s plus 1 plus B over s plus
4 and I cross multiply and I get
something like a plus B times s plus 4 a
plus B divided by my denominator and so
to equate the a and B that satisfied
this are the a and B that make the
numerator equal to one Episode my
numerator has to be 1 which means all of
my s terms a plus B has to be 0 ok so a
so B equals minus a and then this term
for a minus a has to equal 1 so 3 a
equals 1 which means a
equals one third and B equals minus one
third super simple partial fractions
okay
so this transfer function G G of s is
equal to one-third times 1 over s plus 1
minus one-third times 1 over s plus 4 so
what's the inverse Laplace transform of
my fancy transfer function we know how
to do each of these inverse Laplace
transforms that are easy so this is 1/3
eetu the minus t minus 1/3 e to the
minus 14 okay so it's super simple now
to compute this inverse Laplace
transform of my transfer function and
the last step is I have to convulsion
with my input function U that's the only
thing I have to do now ok so the last
step now I'll actually just write it out
explicitly I guess so we have our
particular solution sorry our
homogeneous solution with no forcing and
then we have this convolution which is
an integral from let's say one third of
an integral from minus infinity to
infinity of that function which is e to
the minus t minus e to the minus 4t
these should be towels times my function
U of t minus tau D tau
okay I just pulled the 1/3 out cuz I
didn't like it being inside the integral
of bugging it
okay so we have now we have a full
solution to this Oh de with forcing
right we started with our initial system
X double dot plus Phi of X dot plus 4x
equals U of T we've applause transform
both sides we isolated X bar in terms of
our initial conditions and our forcing
function we essentially did partial
fractions on both of these terms and
simplified and then we inverse Laplace
transforms and we got our particular
homogeneous solution plus this
convolution integral which is our
forcing term and it's essentially
convolving our forcing you with the
dynamics of our Oh de e to the minus tau
and e to the minus 4 tau okay this is a
good time to stop and ask for questions
yeah
yeah yeah that's a really good point so
this is you know one over s squared plus
5 s plus 4 is really equal to 1 over s
plus 1 times 1 over s plus 4 so it
stands to reason that if I inverse
Laplace transform this this is you know
L inverse of this thing equals e to the
minus T convolution with e to the minus
4 key that what your what you mean and I
think that must be true and I must get
something like this without one third
popping out no I really mean four minus
infinity to infinity so my T is right
here so conversely I could have had t
minus tau t minus tau and this could
have been detailed like this could have
been tower you can switch which of the
terms has the t minus tau and the Tau
it's no problem this bound though is so
you're asking a really good question
in practice this bound might be from 0
minus to infinity it might be just
before 0 to infinity because I'm kind of
assuming that nothing was happening
before times 0 times 0 is the beginning
of the universe as far as I'm concerned
and I don't care what was happening
before that yeah so oftentimes I'll
replace this with like 0 minus which
just means just before 0 yeah
curly brackets before a used to get
curly brackets and I just saw was
slipping by Laplace it's just as nice to
you know I'm always doing this of some
function of another variable and so I
don't like having too many round
brackets no not really I if I had
thought a little more I would have done
it for Fourier transforms too like
usually you do it for 40 Elsa okay so we
can do this all in MATLAB which is what
I'm going to show you this whole thing
you can do in MATLAB not exactly sure
let's see yeah okay good I'll show you
this in MATLAB okay other questions
first
so what are some you functions that I
might want to try signed some cosines
maybe I forced my system sinusoidally I
just give it some input that's a sine
wave good well it's another one impulse
maybe I hit my system with a hammer
another function Delta function is an
impulse yeah so that's the hammer a step
function would be good so let's say that
I just turn on my control what time zero
and I keep it on forever turn the lights
on step input those are some functions I
might want to do and fortunately each of
those functions has a relatively simple
form that I can actually do this
convolution integral so in the homework
five that will be posted by the end of
the day you were going to be solving
these types of Odie's and you're
actually going to be by hand solving
this convolution integral for particular
use like a step function or a delta
function or a sine or a cosine and for
example if this U is a step function
it's super easy because it's just 1 from
0 to infinity so you just multiply this
by 1 easy okay Delta functions are also
easy but you'll get some experience
actually solving this convolution
integral by hand for some particular use
even better ways to solve this is not to
do it using this convolution integral
maybe I won't have you solve it by hand
because it's kind of stupid the better
thing to do would be to solve this in
the frequency domain so I have
essentially my system my my solution X
and the frequency domain is my transfer
function G of s times the Laplace
transform of my input function U okay so
what your another thing you're gonna do
on the homework is you're gonna show
that if u of t if u of t is a delta
function then U of S is 1 that's super
nice I multiply my transfer function by
1 and i inverse Laplace transform it
convolution with nothing okay if my U of
T is a step function at time 0 this is
the Heaviside function it goes from 0 to
1 then my U of S is just 1 over s so I
take G of s my transfer function times 1
over s I get a third order polynomial on
the bottom I would really get 1 over s
times s squared plus 5 s plus 4 I can
factor this denominator into 3 partial
fractions and I can inverse Laplace
transform each of those so this one
super simple to solve without using
convolution okay so for lots of common
use that I like to use like impulses and
steps I can actually simplify the system
in the frequency domain and then inverse
Laplace transform the product and I
don't have to think about convolution
because I don't like thinking about
convolution it's a little convoluted ok
so you're in the homework you're going
to by hand show that the Laplace
transform of this is this that's easy
it's just an integral and then you're
going to use those properties to solve
systems by solving them in the Laplace
domain and inverse Laplace transform
okay I'm going to show you how to do
some of this in MATLAB before I go any
further okay again this is a tremendous
field that is used in lots and lots and
lots of other classes and I'm just
giving you kind of the faintest
intuition about what we're doing here
okay so clear all clothes all CLC does
anyone remember what CLC does here's
your command window okay so let's just
put some comments here so my OD E is the
second derivative of X plus d x dot X
plus K times X equals U of T I'm just
gonna use D for damping K for spring
it's easy and what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna say s equals a transfer function
so in MATLAB there's this really slick
command called TF and it makes a
transfer function and so this is how I
initialize my Laplace variable s so in
MATLAB I'm going to be able to do
symbolic stuff in terms of this Laplace
variable because I'm creating a transfer
function which is just s my Laplace
variable okay
then what I'm going to do is I'm going
to say my system equals 1 divided by I
should probably pick a D and a K what
was my D 5k was for okay so I'm going to
have my system be 1 divided by s squared
plus 5 s plus 4
I'm gonna save this as test applause and
I'm gonna run it first of all so nothing
went wrong and if I uncomment this you
see my MATLAB window telling me that I
have a system 1 over s squared plus 5 s
plus 4 and it's a continuous time
transfer function this is built into the
student version of MATLAB it's in the
controls toolbox okay so I have my
transfer function and in MATLAB I can do
really slick things like I can take the
impulse response of my transfer function
and that's the impulse response of my
transfer function so if I gave this
thing a delta function at time 0 in the
input this is what the position of my
spring mass system would do it would
rise and then decay back to where it was
ok I'm going to show you mathematically
how to derive this I can also do things
like look at the step response so if I
step my system if I just take my initial
force and I increase my force to some
value like 1 then the position of my
spring mass system just goes up to some
steady state value and it has some
transient motion yeah both of these are
receiving 0 initial conditions I can
give my system an initial condition
response using the initial command but I
never do so I don't know how to use it I
guess it's easy initial system X naught
so if I wanted to give this an initial
condition I could do that also okay so
it's really easy to define these
transfer functions in MATLAB and it's
also easy to get basic information that
I want out of the system so let's do
something a little simple a little more
interesting so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna change the damping rate
and let's pick a spring constant K
equals one so for D equals point one in
increments of 0.1 to two so I'm going to
change my damping rate from very lightly
damped to pretty heavily damped in
increments of 0.1 for each of these DS
I'm gonna recreate my system I'm gonna
say sis equals 1 divided by s squared
plus D times s plus K and then what I'm
gonna do is I'm going to look at the
step of my system you know look at the
step response of my system I'll pause
for a dramatic pause and I will hold my
graph so that we can see then building
up over time any questions about what
we're doing I have my system it's
parametrized by D and K and so in MATLAB
I can go through and just do this for a
bunch of D's in a bunch of K's so I'm
gonna do this for a bunch of damping
rates and hopefully this will work and I
will plot the system as it becomes more
and more damped color schemes kind of
awful but you can see that for low D I
have big oscillations
maybe I'll not hold on maybe I'll hold
off you see it becomes less and less
damped and eventually becomes like
critically damped sorry becomes more and
more damped until it becomes critically
damped does that make sense
ok let's also do the same thing but
let's change the spring constants okay
so now D is gonna be one I just have
some damping for K equals point 1 2
point 1 to 2 so now my spring constants
becoming stiffer and stiffer same thing
system equals I can just copy all of
this
now as my spring key becomes stiffer and
stiffer then my effective damping
becomes less and less and it becomes
more more springy right it becomes more
and more when I make my spring stiffer
even for constant damping which is why
we introduce these new parameters Zeta
and Omega sometimes because K and
damping are kind of bad parameters
they're not independent really okay lots
of cool stuff you can do in MATLAB super
simple using transfer functions okay
questions more questions about the
MATLAB before I go back to the board
yeah yeah so that's called Elson doc
Ellison this just means linear
simulation and so I'm gonna do L sim of
my system with some input vector U and
some time vector T so let's do that
let's say that let's say T equals 0.1 in
increments of 0.1 to 10 to 100 and let's
say that u equals sine of T and let's
say that my output is equal to L sin of
my system call me u comma T I think
that's how I do it and then I'm gonna
plot T by the output maybe I'll call
this X because my system is X okay so
this is my system response to a
sinusoidal input there's some transients
but eventually it also the output looks
sinusoidal and that makes sense right if
I take my spring mass system and I start
sinusoidally forcing it there's some
transient but eventually the output also
starts looking sinusoidal and it has the
same frequency as the sinusoidal input
that I'm giving it okay this is a
perfect segue into the next part of what
I was going to tell you about which is
the frequency response to sinusoidal
inputs
okay so a little bit more MATLAB they're
a little more math and then a little bit
more MATLAB so this function G of s is
extremely important this transfer
function G of s tells me essentially
everything about my OD e it tells me how
my OD e will handle initial conditions
it tells me how my OD e will handle
external forcing and there's lots of
powerful and useful things I can do in
the frequency domain with this transfer
function and there's entire fields
dedicated to understanding this transfer
function and how to manipulate it and
plot it and do all kinds of things with
it
okay so let's say that our transfer
function is called G of s and we have no
initial conditions so so we're gonna
look a little bit more at our transfer
function G of s this thing here okay so
for linear systems like all of the
systems we've been looking at linear
partial differential equations linear
ordinary differential equations if I
give my system a sinusoidal input then I
get a sinusoidal output at the same
frequency but with a different magnitude
and some different phase does that make
sense I force the system with the
sinusoid I get a sinusoid but it might
have a different phase it might be a co
sinusoid and it has a different
amplitude so the idea here is that I
have my my transfer function G of s this
is my physical system and let's say I
give it some sine Omega T as the input U
of T equals sine Omega T as my input
it's my system and the output X of T is
going to be the same frequency sine but
it's going to have a new amplitude and
some phase this is always true for
linear systems so this is for linear
systems this is always true at least in
the steady state there might be some
transients but this will happen for like
once the system's reach steady state and
the transient died out
okay so this a is the magnitude and this
fee is the phase and so the idea is that
we can get the magnitude and the phase
of what our system does to sinusoidal
inputs by looking at this transfer
function this transfer function is going
to tell us how our system handles inputs
of different frequencies and what the
magnitude and phase of the outputs will
be for those given frequencies so
basically I have a as a function of
Omega and I have V as a function of
Omega and I want to know what these
functions are because this tells me a
lot of information about how my system
responds okay and the way we do this is
we say essentially the magnitude and
phase of output to a sinusoidal input is
given by can be solved by the transfer
function so it's given by the transfer
function evaluated at that frequency so
evaluated at s equals I Omega so I
literally take G of I Omega write my
transfer function is a function of my
Laplace variable s s is a complex number
so I can take G of I Omega this is sines
and cosines at frequency Omega and this
is a complex number
I mean just verify plug in I Omega into
that transfer function you get a complex
number right it's a complex function and
so what we have is that we can look at
the magnitude of G I Omega just what is
the raw magnitude of this complex number
that's a that's my amplitude and fee is
the essentially the angle of this
complex number so just how do i how do I
find the angle of a complex number
what is angle of a plus bi
it's the arctangent of B over a it's
just what is but like literally in the
complex plane I have a plus bi what is
this angle it's arctangent of B over a
so that's what angle means it's what is
the phase angle so the phase is the
phase angle of my transfer function at I
Omega okay and the great thing is is
that these are both functions of Omega I
can do this for all Omega I can do this
for really really low frequencies I can
do this for really really high
frequencies and I can do this for all
frequencies in between and I get numbers
a of Omega and fee of Omega I get my
amplitude and my phase for any input
frequency Omega that you like and I can
plot these as a function of Omega so
this is called the frequency response or
the bode plots
there was a great engineer named bode I
must name my dog bode but I don't think
it's a great dog name and you can draw
the bode plot for your system so I'll
just draw the bode plot for the
spring-mass system and then explain what
it means up here we're gonna have the
magnitude of GI Omega and down here
we're gonna have the phase of GI Omega
and for our system what we have is it
stays constant for a while and then it
starts to drop off and my phase starts
out at zero and then at some point it
starts to go down to minus one eight to
minus 180 Omega and amplitude are on a
log scale angle is just in degrees it's
not on a log scale okay so I want to
tell you what this means physically with
my spring mass system so this is
actually for my spring mass system now
would you say that this is highly damped
or lightly damped lightly damped there's
not a lot of friction it's just a coil
it's a coil so because my system is
lightly damped I'm probably actually
gonna have more of a peak here I'll
explain this peak and I will also
probably drop down and phase more
rapidly this is something you'll learn
about in control theory but let's start
thinking about what we mean physically
how we physically read this frequency
response [ __ ] maybe I should have a
different example that doesn't tangle
okay so the idea is
let's say that I start forcing the
system at a really really low frequency
really low frequency what this tells me
is that my magnitude is going to be
basically one this is one and it's going
to be in phase with my motion so let's
do this really slowly really slow
sinusoid and the position of my mass is
tracking my position at the exact same
amplitude this isn't stretching or
contracting okay so that's unit
magnitude and this is at some you know
there's some frequency below which the
phone perfectly tracks the input forcing
perfectly unit magnitude zero phase now
at some frequency there's a resonance so
I give it a little bit of force and I
can get this thing to basically jump
around this is a tiny displacement and
the phone's jumping and it's at about
ninety degrees out of phase so it's a
little hard to see that from this
example but if my hands doing a sign the
phone is doing a cosine may be a minus
cosine it's doing something cosinusoidal
and then finally what we find and this
increase here in magnitude means that
I'm actually getting more motion out of
my phone that I'm putting in right it's
an increase in my amplitude out and
finally at very very high frequencies
what this is predicting is that the
magnitude of the phone motion actually
becomes very very small and it becomes
out of phase with my hand motion so this
one's a little harder for me to do but
if I move this thing really really
really fast [ __ ] starts flipping because
it's a coil not a spring but if I move
it really really really fast you can see
that this phone is actually not going up
and down very quickly like it's actually
not going up and down at all if my hands
moving unit 1 then this phone might be
moving like 1 centimeter and its motion
is going to be exactly out of face so
when my hand moves up it's gonna move
down and then when my hand moves down
it's gonna move up right so it's
completely out of face I don't like this
phone very much
okay does that basically make sense in
terms of how to read this this frequency
response this bode plots and it's really
easy to evaluate the frequency response
using my transfer function I I have a
function of s and I can plug numbers
into that and I can find out what the
magnitude and the phase of the complex
numbers are that come out okay let's do
this in MATLAB I have a few more minutes
okay so basically the first thing I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna change the damping
rate like I did but instead of plugging
the step response I'm gonna plot the
bode plot and now I am gonna hold on
so bode is the command in MATLAB that
does this frequency response it's named
after bode and we can see our bode plot
as I increase the amount of damping so
imagine I made that coil stiffer and
stiffer and stiffer so it was more and
more not stiffer I increase the damping
so I made it more and more and more
damped you see that I initially had this
big resonant peak which means that if I
give it a little forcing at the resonant
frequency then the output amplifies but
as I increase the damping my resonant
peak is damped so damping means right i
damped my resonant peak and I also you
know for higher resonant Peaks my phase
change happens much more rapidly I could
do the same thing if I change my spring
constant instead so now as I change my
my spring constant so I make this thing
stiffer and stiffer you see that now if
I give this thing order one input the
output response gets smaller and smaller
and the frequency where resonance occurs
gets higher and higher right as I
increase the stiffness the resonant
frequency gets higher we know this Omega
naught right
the square root of K over or something
and it gets higher and higher when K
goes up and you can I mean this is a
great engineering diagram because you
can literally tell exactly what your
system is going to do at any frequency
by reading two numbers off of this plot
it's great and as we know from linear
systems Fourier transforms and Laplace
transforms are linear so any signal I
make even a step function I can break up
into a sigh a sum of sines and cosines
and so I can look at how different
frequency components of my step will
either be amplified or decay and some of
my step might have a resonance and so
that frequency might oscillate a little
bit in my step response and we'll look
at this a little bit more okay and
basically out of time I think I will
probably continue a little bit more in
this vein on Monday do a little bit more
analysis on these frequency responses in
the Laplace transform and what it means
any questions about what we've done
before in the last minute or two okay I
owe you a homework it'll be out later
today so sometime before midnight there
will be a homework all right thank you